[Music]
I reject nation Greg Alba here this
weekend sees Incredibles - and tag
coming out but I'm gonna talk about a
little indie film called American
animals I actually saw this a week and a
half ago because of III going on didn't
really have time to cover this movie I
want to talk about it with you guys
right now because I think it's a film
more people should be watching it's
expanding in more theaters this is not
some paid promo video just think you
guys should go watch this movie so I saw
the trailer for this film I thought
stylistically it looked really cool
though I was a little confused on what
was going on in the movies what I'm so
confused
so I've got here the Wikipedia and the
IMDB plot description to make it easier
for you guys to follow it's based on the
true story about four dudes who live out
in Lexington Kentucky this takes place
in 2004 it's about them trying to pull
off a heist stealing a priceless Audubon
prints and rare books from a Special
Collections library that happened at the
Transylvania University I want to keep
this review short because I just want
more people to go check this movie out
so this is based on a true story it's a
wildly entertaining film it's a crazy
story with characters who are reckless
pence American animals there's something
relatable about them because the biggest
inspiration for what makes them think
they can pull off this heist is their
inspiration from watching heist movies
it's a big part that comes into play
with this film when they're literally
trying to figure out how to pull off
this heist
they started studying heist movies when
that started happening I really
connected with the film not because I've
tried pulling off a heist I connected
with it because I think there's so many
of us who will often watch badass
characters in movies or even criminals
watch like an Ocean's eleven type of
film or the sting or any type of outlaw
character and go their badass they did
it I want to be like them I thought it
was fascinating to watch a story about
young dudes who've watched too many
movies and thought they could be these
guys this director primarily has a
documentary background so about twenty
to thirty percent of this movie is
actually cutting back and forth between
interviews with the real for dudes who
pulled off this heist part of the unique
narrative with this storytelling is
there's often conflicting point of views
often over my new details like very
little things like what
shirt was this guy wearing that they met
with but I thought it was a fascinating
narrative because so many times you see
movies that are based on a true story
and you end up questioning and this
actually happened and this actually
happened and this actually happened I
thought it was fascinating for the movie
itself to have conflicting interviews
present both interviews for the movie
itself to be questioning did this
actually happen to this part actually
have I think in the first act it gets a
little too hyper stylized with showing
what they're trying to do with the
narrative with the conflicting
perspectives from interviewing the four
people have different versions of
certain events oh let's have Evan Peters
break away from the scene for a second
and start talking to the actual dude who
he's portraying this stuff like that
where I thought it was a little too much
a little too flashy at first I thought I
probably wouldn't be able to fully get
invested into this film because I
thought its style was a little too in my
face but after a while the style blends
very seamlessly that when it's cutting
back and forth from the interviews and
then the reenactment you're just
invested in both that's going on I think
the direction of this film is really
cool especially in the tone that the
director struck with the film because
it's not one of those movies like in
Ocean's eleven where it's just a giant
build up to a heist and then after the
heist has done the movie ends the movie
kind of has two halves everything before
the heist
then the heist and everything after that
because everything leading up to the
heist is really seeing it from the
perspective of these dudes who really
believe they can pull this heist off
these are just young men who are doing
this so in the style that the director
was choosing to capture the reenactment
its captured in a way as if you're
watching a really bitchin heist movie
and you think these guys are gonna pull
off some crazy cool heist and then the
last half is when it gets real it gets
super realistic like when they get to
the actual heist it's not some cool
badass thing it's scary it's
nerve-racking you feel like pacing the
room because of how like oh my god I
thought it was so cool to see a movie
that is essentially telling you life
isn't a movie just because you saw some
cool stuff go down in a film doesn't
mean you can pull it off in real life
and it's also more than just fulfilling
fantasies scene from a movie these guys
really just hate the idea of conforming
to what society wants them to be like so
the first half cool badass plotting of a
heist movie and then the last half hits
you with a large dose of somber
realism but it works perfectly and the
cast of the four dudes are great the
four dudes have pull off this heist
they're all great actors and they do the
fantastic job and have unique
personalities here but the main actor to
talk about is the lead of this movie and
the guy who leads this whole heist Evan
Peters as Warren Lipka who's the main
guy who brought his buddies together
I've seen most of American Horror Story
and I've said for a long time that I
think Evan Peters is gonna be the next
Johnny Depp not Johnny Depp today like
oh my god a word about giant duck young
Johnny Depp there's something about the
not giving a [ __ ] personality that he
has and the delivery and his ability to
embody of a wide variety of roles that
really reminds me of a young Johnny Depp
his performance here showcases that this
dude can lead the hell out of a movie
he's an eccentric character a dude who
when he's convinced he's good at
convincing other people of what he's
convinced himself up even though this is
a crazy idea this dude is a guy who does
not seem like he's headed down a good
path you can see why he was able to
gather people smarter than himself and
get them believing that they all could
pull off this crazy heist
these four young men who don't want to
conform to the norms of society want to
live in this fantasy world and have the
easy way out you come to learn that life
isn't a movie I really think you guys
should go watch this film it's a
fascinating true story with a unique
narrative an awesome soundtrack by the
way with some great performances in it
and it has the veil of a cool heist
movie but it's a film that's much deeper
than that it's a film that's about
choices it's a film about consequences
and about how fulfilling certain
fantasies does not equate to having a
good reality I was seriously wildly
impressed with the film it's very
stylish it's very well acted very well
directed for a film with this kind of
pacing and great dark comedy I was
surprised by how much deeper it actually
is I would agree this on a scale out of
10 I would give it like an 8.5 or a 9
out of 10 it is seriously one of my
favourite movies of the year it's a film
that I saw a week and a half ago and I
thought about it every day since it's a
damn good movie Evan Peters kills it and
I hope that when awards season comes
around he is considered for Best leading
Actor
all right guys why don't you comment
below and tell me what is your favorite
heist movie you guys can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification bell and you can check us
on patreon full-length TV show reactions
weekly Q&A s but loved
have you become a patron object today